You need to wipe down.
What's with the jeans?
No.
Yeah.
What'd you got? Jeans. Where are you
at? Where I'm at, Yo. Friday night
I'm going to be in Los Angeles. Oh,
you are? Where are you going to do?
I'm doing the Improv lab. Oh,
that's fine. I just did that.
You're going to like that.
You go to the Melrose Improv.
They have a small room
next to the main room.
10:00 PM show John Doors on the
show and he picks on the show.
It's comedy living room. Andy.
Dick. Alright. How many living rooms
next week?
Cleveland steamer coming out
Saturday already has a sold out show.
Uh, the second Saturday. Show his clothes.
Still tickets available for Thursday
and um, a couple left for Friday.
But if you haven't yet scooped up
your tickets for Cleveland steamer,
you're going to be out of
luck soon. Um, additionally,
I know I'm going to sperm can,
uh, that's in Washington
and the state of Washington.
That's at the end of April in Spokane.
April 20th through 23rd. They don't
know where to go, how many clubs.
It's brand new. And then
Jack me off. Phil Florida.
God won the comedy zone.
Nailed it.
April 5th through seventh is on sale
to Sharon syringe and cues. I
Dunno. What does that one again?
Second, second cues. Syracuse, New
York. We'll think we'll work on that.
April 20th 21st it's on sale.
Here's a couple others that are on sale.
They're a ways away, but they
are already selling tickets. Uh,
Carolines on Broadway in New York City.
It's April 8th through 10th and then
the truck at Arrow Trocadero theatre and
fart load delve, mia fill, fill her up.
Delphia Pennsylvania like fart
load Delphia to fart load.
Delphia Pennsylvania.
That is November 19th.
That is more than half
soles and it's a ways away.
November. Oh my God. Yeah. They're going
to have to add more shows. I don't know.
We'll see. Um, so that's where
we're at. Jeans for me. Nice.
Um, okay. This Friday I'm at the comedy
store. The eight o'clock, I'm sorry,
Saturday,
I'm probably into the Saturday
eight o'clock show and
then up in the valley room.
I am a spot there. If you're at the,
if you're in town and you're like, Hey,
I want to see some rad comics,
stop by the store on Saturday,
she'll probably see Joe Rogan
or, or, uh, Bill Burr, who knows?
And [inaudible]. Uh, and
then April 1st and second,
I am headlining the flip Paris comedy
club and sperm bank in April one and two.
And then April 7th, the Irvine
improve sperm bank. Oh yeah.
And the Irvine Improve
Improv or nervine April 7th,
April 7th and then May 27th of May 28th,
the comedy store in La Jolla.
You have all these memorized.
It's not that many.
Well, there's only like four things
and I like you. You're, you're,
you're Mab Dad till
November, man. Alright. Genes
December, I've got December.
Oh my gosh. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
So you've got way more in your head
and the 90 right now. Okay. All right.
Well I'm impressed though. You're just
like Bam, Bam, Bam. I'm, you know,
I lived through it. You don't
understand. You know what I'm saying?
You know what I mean? You
feel me? I'm talking about.
Don't know what you're saying
and I don't know what you do,
man. I don't know what you mean.
It's amazing. It's amazing.
What is amazing? What a
world. We have a show for you,
so much to share, to do for you. No,
not at this wonderful villa.
I will get railed by two gentlemen.
Okie dokie. And My asshole,
Babe. Sweetie, we can't
say that on the show. Um,
are you ready to Party by two gentlemen?
Only if there's two gentlemen that
are going to show up. All right,
well let's do this and I'm,
Oh no, dad. Dad, are you ready to do this?
Yeah, the show. Hey.
Okay.
Oh,
hello.
With Red Bud.
Don't bring anyone loving to them.
Well,
well go to your mom's house.
Own Surgical,
Christina.
All
right.
Yeah,
it's
like frying it in there. It's a little
lie. Well, we got through it, so
listen to the show too loud.
There you go.
This a blue band. Find this.
Did you find this? This clip?
We just get it. Did it just
come in or something? Yeah,
yeah. Oh, I sent it to you.
So someone sent it to me.
That's what it was.
But this has absolutely made my weekend.
He's such a dad. He's an ultimate.
Then it's a, it's, it's,
it's labeled as a meme,
which is dad discovers
memes for the first time.
He absolutely loses us
front of mind and he really,
I mean the laughter is
other level, you know? Um,
let me pull up the,
I think the full version.
I think your dad were that the rack
like this to my dad leaving thing,
I'll be like, this is really funny. You
would like it. He would like it or not.
He would be like, that's funny,
but there'll be no laughter.
Like there's no feelings.
You know,
your dad would think that's a really
goofy to laugh this. Well. He'd be like,
this fucking guy doesn't want
to get laid obviously. Right.
This guy doesn't give lead how much you
think he gets let your dad so more than
you ever would imagine it. More than you
ever. Well, you know what I'm saying?
Like probably ever will. Yeah. Yeah. First
of all, you know, I asked him one time,
I was like, how many women do you think
you've been with? And he goes, not enough.
That was about five years ago. It's
the right answer for him. Yeah.
We had a conversation.
Not even that indirectly led to some
numbers where I was like, seriously? Yeah.
Yeah. You got numbers. Well,
I didn't get all time numbers.
I got numbers on one trip.
One trip, one of his trips.
Can you please tell me it was pretty high?
What is it,
those double digits for like
a weekend in Club med? No.
Does this club med in the 80s no, he did
tell me about one trip. Okay. Tell me.
I mean really? Yeah. He said it was
a Cruisey went on a cruise one time.
Oh, he's only ever been on
like one gates cruises. Yeah.
Maybe that's why when he said it was
stupid, but he fucked like 10 checks.
Seriously? Yeah. Well I don't
even know this about my dad.
I know. That's so crazy.
Yeah.
When did he tell you this?
We were just talking about not even
about checks and he was like, yeah, fuck,
like 10 checks on it. No where, where were
you? Where were we when this happened?
Or was I not in the room?
Was this somebody out in the ocean? No,
no, no, no, no, no. It was recently.
This is recent. This is like him
in our house and you're like, yeah,
you gotta be shitting me. No, no.
Like our baby. Like, he's like, oh,
look at the baby by the way. Yeah. Like
the fuck like 10 girls one time. Yeah.
It's pretty nuts. A that
like, wait, what? Why are you
bringing this? Yeah. Like that.
How did it come out? Uh, I think
you were talking about trips,
like vacations and I was like, yeah, I
hate cruises. He's like, yeah, me too.
I went on this one. It's suck the fuck
like 10 checks. That was a low day.
It was a low number. Him. Yeah.
Unreal. Yeah, man. He's a savage.
That guy's DNA is core. Like
that's half of me. It's so weird.
It's crazy that you don't have more
siblings that you know about. Oh,
I'm sure I do. You really think you
do? Sure. Just like some third world.
Thailand somewhere. Yeah. Philippines.
Devily Columbia. So my name is luck.
Luck. Budzinski yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Can we watch the dad mean please?
Okay.
It's so cute.
So much real joy and all of that.
What means did he looking at first
time you really realize he truly is
discovering this? Yeah. This is the new,
like so new to him and
he can't get over half.
It's like a baby discovering
your face or something. Yeah.
What a nerd.
And what is it like cat?
He can't wrap his head around.
It doesn't have a lot other things.
You know what I mean? Like
our minds, me, it's okay
Gig.
It's like
multiple,
multiple choice questions.
Jesus.
It really is like,
Oh yeah,
I've seen my dad. Like, see, you know,
something like this that you thinks is
funny and just laugh like, like that.
Like this. Yeah. Okay. Danny, really? Lou,
usually your dad does laugh at
himself the most is his thought. Yeah.
But sometimes if he, you know, if he
thinks it's fun to see him more um,
Vietnam or the Holocaust,
like what's Funnier to your dad?
Probably now because it's all those
fun memories. No. Yeah, probably no.
Yeah,
it's just a lot of bodies buddy.
Can we get through it? The red, but
yeah.
What?
I have to know the meme now it's killing
me that we can't see what you ordered
is yeah,
totally
success kid success kid.
Okay,
let's look at that success kid. Yeah,
that's good. Basic need, but like,
okay.
You don't probably won't know.
See now I feel like with dad,
cause I don't know it. Right.
Well let's see if you lose your
fucking mind. You, I don't know. Okay.
What Dad's loving yet. He loves it like
a dad got his stuff. Oh, there he is.
Okay.
That's cute.
That's what he was laughing at.
What are the 10 piece?
Chicken mcnugget got 11 I got
knocked down and they get up again.
That's shamble. Womba
okay. All right. Wait,
thought today was Thursday.
It's Friday playing peekaboo with mine.
I can see her. I pooped in my
pants and made my mom clean it.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. It's not as funny as
I'd hoped. Well, that's what I thought.
It was a funny, she really, I do
like the Ryan Gosling ones. Oh,
like this. He's like the sweaters made a
boyfriend, which I think that's stupid.
And then there's one going around
that's like cat or muffin. Oh No, no.
Chihuahua or Muffin. Come on.
You don't like that? Sorry. Oh,
come on. It's good. You really
liked that. Yeah. I mean,
that's really cute and thought
like really a creative. Yeah,
my fender chihuahuas. Really good.
What do you think of? Damn Daniel.
Are you into that? Oh, sat. That's the
video. You don't know. Damn Daniel. No,
I don't know that she uses your fucking,
I've been out of the loop guys. This is,
um, this is like, you know all
the kids. Oh, I'll the hipsters.
Is this like Nan Danielle,
Danielle
back at it again with the wide Dan Daniel,
Daniel. Damn. Daniel,
Daniel,
Daniel back at it again with
the white vans guys. The men,
Danielle.
So don't, and then they, these
kids, this thing blew up so crazy.
They got a modeling contract
offered to this kid. Your kid,
I swear he's a snappy dresser.
Snappy Dresser. And then his buddy.
Why'd you haven't been hearing the words?
Damn Daniel in the last 24 hours. Oh,
we can't use the interwebs.
Oh, okay. Anyways,
we know who that is on the Internet. No
Shit. This guy's funny. Whatever, man.
Yes. Um, what's it called? A fair usage.
You know what I mean?
There's, yeah, it's, it's uh,
it's exploded the Damn Daniel Movement.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, he's really cute.
Like Daniel's got good fashion sense.
He shuts off league.
I just ordered some vans myself.
Okay.
Danielle.
Danielle,
you want me to say it? You're supposed to
say it. You know, I walk out of the room.
You go
damn Daniel. Damn Daniel.
Yeah, I like that.
Write it into your life. No,
no, no. Yeah, I like it. Now.
You're not such a mom. Boner
total mama. You know what I've had on a
fucking Lupe and I don't want to find,
now I'm probably introducing it,
but is shout out to everybody out there
doing that thing and stuff like that.
I had it set it up on a pho four in the
morning I was up and I said it to myself
a hundred times.
Shout out to everybody out there all
over the world doing that day and stuff
like that and stuff like that is the
best all over the world. Everyone,
everyone doing this as a civilization
shut up every human homosapien upon by
peds.
Well, um, shout out to dogs if you
don't know what we're talking about.
Talking about crazy legs.
Who by the way,
hello key responded to us. So I can't
believe, and I haven't seen it yet.
You didn't call us out by name,
but what do you, you know, smart.
I issued the challenge, right? We're
all right. He was talking crazy legs.
If you want to spar, blah,
blah blah. Yeah, and this is
what his response was. Okay,
I love you. Jesus. Crazy Los right here.
Yeah.
Oh really?
So not even one to one if
praise you most desire.
So y'all quiz low fee is on.
So he's directly responding to people
saying is he mentally stable and well,
crazy legs is telling you I'm all there.
That he's there.
Yeah,
that has to do take it again for real.
It just dial one the one place.
Love the shuffling his foot
and the team at the same time.
Saw that train to tell me for real style.
I should want to one guy.
Why quiz low speed come in with his
boxing with punches and punches.
Cause he keeps it Washin. Yup. Yep.
If he wants to tie me, he
fills Ikea. He real shit.
No side.
Yeah.
The message there.
They want the one duck.
Why my knuckles are like
no, that is a swollen ass knuckle
for real big. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
That's not normal at all. Really?
Hell No. Look at the size of that.
He's a professional fighter. Oh that's a
stretch. But he, yeah, he tells you why.
Listen what he says
from the new and my knuckles and
hitting the bag would know too low.
So
eat up style shall goals outside of clans,
you know,
for change changing.
I thought you said your name.
I thought he was about to tell
everybody who's seen it goes, oh,
and they gave me the time code.
They're like at one 13 when he goes
time a change and it was exciting.
But yeah,
Lowe's is stay persistent with eight fine.
Yup.
For real self
as it these days. Yeah. No, yeah,
no.
Yeah.
Anybody else form crazy
louts ESOP to be good.
Work me that pleasure.
God bless.
Bye.
Wow. Hey, I will say, yeah,
this guy is focused. He directed
his energy at you. Yeah,
I wouldn't fuck with crazy lugs
now. I mean that fuck with them. No,
but I say no the Walmart, but it was
playful. He was like, Yo, what's up?
This is good. And that was like
focused energy. Yeah. He's really,
he's in it to win it with you. So Gora
well I had a little something to say back.
Okay.
I love the Buddha.
Check it out.
People talk and wondering,
does buttons have,
the Cardio has cardio.
They want wonder if
buzz can duck and move.
Well it was the duck and move.
Don't watch out too fast for you
to even see cause he keeps pushing.
You got the finger on it.
Stuff like that. Check it.
People wonder,
how is he so powerful
because of the train.
Because I never stop pushing all the
time I was here and appreciates any
challenges for anybody who wants to step
into the ring for sparring session and
deliver pleasure.
So anytime any nor cal folks
that are saying or crazy,
you want to get up with it,
Holler at me man.
You know where to find me anytime.
I appreciate it.
You all love to everybody
all over the world.
Did you read my thing? Stuff like that.
You just threw down the gauntlet and,
and I like that you kind of took a
veiled approach the way he do with you.
So you're meeting him where he's at.
That's what I'm doing.
That's a really smart way to do things.
Talk to my agent today. You were? Yeah.
I said, uh, we think about San
Jose. Uh, cause that's where,
that's where my man lives. Oh, well
you were, okay. So you went up,
you want to find a venue and San Jose?
No,
I'm saying like if I can get a date book
there. Okay. Then I can also sketch,
try to pursue scholarly. Wow. You
know, throwing down. Yeah man.
Shout out to just go spar, you know,
shout out to all of those crazies thang.
Um,
he should really wrap his knuckles.
He should at least the very least.
Yeah, that one is really, oof.
It's really bad. Well he's, I think
he's fired up. I think he's really, um,
he's focused energy. He really focused
on you. I mean, I don't know on you,
on someone. I don't know. I mean, I
don't know what else. I don't know.
I want to generally make it real clear
that, um, you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying? I got a lot
of, uh, you know, Sam, respect and stuff.
You feel me? You feel me all the time
out. So this is all, it's all good.
It's all a, it's all
good. Yeah. Shout out,
shout out to everybody doing they thing,
stuff like stuff like that. I like when
you do it, can you do it for me now?
What's that? The first time we
got, cause you do the head thing,
you gotta shout out to everybody,
shout to everybody by all over
the world doing the thing,
stuff like that. And you know,
you feel me? You know what I mean?
Talking about Katie looks is fire up.
You know what I would love is if he wrote
a song about this and then if you guys
could rap battle, lovey, cooler.
You know what I want to address
is something came in you.
You mentioned something during our ads,
this episode,
and then there's something kind of related
to it in an email. Let's see. It says,
Dear Tom and Tina, I've listened to
your mom's house since episode two.
What I would consider myself
a bit of a mom cast historian
during the heat of the
Fedex Fedex scandal.
I had that little tickle in
the back of my brain saying,
I remember you guys discussing Fedex
podcasts.
Alas, alas, I wrote it off,
but a few weeks ago I decided,
you know what?
I'm going to get to the bottom of this.
So starting from episode 44 I listen
to all of your podcasts through and
through. Oh my God, I'm happy
to report. I fucking found it.
No, I am age episode one 51
I won't go into much detail.
I'll just give you a timestamp.
Hopefully this whole debacle can be laid
to rest when a certain main mommy says
FedEx the proper way.
Thank you.
Submitted by Tavin. Is it
Tevin? Tevin. Caban well,
well thanks for submitting whatever piece
of that. Every time his name is said,
residents are playing, they playing at
Fedex field. So you'd say FedEx, Fedex,
economic, that kind of thing. But it isn't
that, at least for me, naming rights,
it's called,
right.
It kills my soul just a little
bit to hear a beautiful stadium.
The maybe some man said,
I love to build a stadium.
Let's let's build a stadium where the
people could get together and congregate.
Amazing way. It's a,
it's a Herculean thing.
And then fucking FedEx comes and they
renamed it the Fedex stadium or blah,
blah, blah. And you're like, no,
no, no. It's not called that.
It's called whatever the
Fuck Wrigley Stadium.
It's called this you piece of shit after
the man who designed it or whatever.
I think a lot kinda throw
fans. Yeah, it's fine.
The audio dropped out. Didn't drop out,
you know? Exactly. I didn't hear that.
The audio, the Nice, well it's a,
it's a Herculean thing and then fucking
FedEx comes and they rename it the Fedex
stadium or blah blah blah. And you're
like, no, no, no. It's not called that.
It's called,
what's your guys?
I can't believe somebody listened to.
Thank you for doing that.
Can You admit your mistake? No, I mean
I dunno what mistake you speak of.
I just know that this is such
nonsense. What? Fedex? No,
I'm saying that fuck says that.
Always said it that way.
Maybe I would had a stutter back
then. That his stutter. Yeah,
that was my speech impediment back
when they had one and then I've been in
treatment and I don't talk about
doing ridiculous. Just not okay.
I don't know.
I didn't hear all that audio,
but okay.
I'm amazed.
First of all,
honor that you listened to so many
episodes and thank you for digging that up
and I rightfully will take my place
on top of mount fed ex the king of the
castle.
Obviously I had said it right as
most of you seem to acknowledge.
So I think you know your place now
and it's, it's, it's at the bottom.
All right. Whatever. Okay. Fedex,
FedEx, Fedex, whatever. Tomato,
tomato,
tomato predicts on good to me
while I was gone by the way,
sac town ball Sacramento was um,
fantastic.
We have a lot to cover there.
We're going to get into
some of the outside details,
but the shows were a lot of fun.
Amazing crowds.
It just have the best fans up there.
Of course
everywhere, same embryo. They all came
out and Brad, it was fun. Thank you.
Mommy's for coming.
I knew you were in there.
I could hear you tell it their mommy's
cause they laugh at certain things.
People don't. It's great. Well it's,
it's also um, it was really neat.
I walked on stage one of my shows and
a girl was sitting in the front row and
with a marker she had written
on her forehead. Hey Hitler.
So you look at a girl marker and
I'm like lipstick, I don't know.
I go, hey killers on your forehead.
She's like, yeah. I'm like,
and all these people were like,
hey, like screaming, hey guys, the club,
the employees were like what is going
on with the girl on the other comment or
the other audience members were like,
why is that going on the Hay?
Hitler theme has been one of my
favorite because it's probably the most
inappropriate thing. We've honored our
permit. It's the most fun. And look,
if you're on board, you're on board.
If you're not, go fuck yourself.
You're not a mommy.
I mean kind of in a way it sort of,
hey so I'm the place I want to shit in
your mouth is actually in your mouth.
I'm hoping that they
actually ride the new place.
The new thing that takes off is this
and what I want to do is to come
that is again on,
cause that Nice Lady,
it was from a national geographic thing.
I said did the series finale of down.
We haven't watched it yet.
That's probably a good point.
Yeah.
I'm saying this to doing some research.
Stumbled on that.
And then that's how you found that.
I think so. Downton research. Yeah.
I was like Oh in 1926 what happened?
And then came out.
What I want to know is this the best,
what I want to know is common.
So hard to find.
Like I just want to give you calm.
You have to really dig for come true.
Yup. Yup. It's all you
know. Well the guy come,
it's always such a hard thing
for men to ejaculate. You know?
It's good that more attention is being
focused on male orgasm gets no attention.
And also I think it's also cool to help
this girl that's trying to find it so
badly cause she's probably her whole
life's like I can't find what I'm looking
for again,
so sneaker load. So when I was gone, um,
you had a conversation loads.
Your Dad,
who you guys didn't talk about
how many chicks he bang on a trip,
but you did have a conversation with him.
Do you want to set it up? Yeah, sure.
So I invited all the pigeons keys over
or my cousins shotty and Julie and
everybody came to see the baby cause
I've been keeping the baby under wraps,
you know. Anyway, they came, uh,
my father has been reminiscing about
how much he hated having a baby,
like pacifically me, not
just a baby. Sure. Yeah,
just me and a,
and so I thought I would interview him
about this theme because every time he
comes over he like loves
Ellis, but he's like, God, God,
La Fuck wouldn't pay me to do that
shit again. I'm like, what do you,
what was so bad about,
about me? He's like, Oh,
you have to lik you're crying
all the time. He hated it.
He just hated the first part of my life.
But then he loved being a dad later
anyway, I just thought I would ask him.
She busted out your phone. Yeah. I just
as a casual interview. Yeah. And um, yeah,
so this is, this is what we were
talking about is the early days of me,
My Life Dad, when tell me about
the best part of parenthood.
Tell me when that starts. Go ahead. At
two months. No, not three months. He said,
oh I'm sorry. Yeah. Three years
after. Yeah. That's the three.
As you can tell the kid the shut
the fuck up. Sit the fuck down.
Go to sleep, leave me alone.
Let me drink my beer. Oh, right.
Cause I heard a lot of that as a kid.
I heard a go play on the freeway. Yes,
of course. Yeah. Whatsoever
that no, nothing. I turned
out amazing. Now obviously.
Yeah, that's right. I see. Yeah.
Tell me about when I was born.
You said it was the best three
months of your life. All of was bad.
That was a worst three months of
my whole life. I never forget.
What was your favorite part about being
a new parent and not the sleep a second.
Wait. So are parents not supposed to
say this kind of stuff to their kids?
Like you guys, I mean, you look at Paul's,
is that normal? I mean, it's a joke.
I know he's a good joke. Yeah,
no, it's done. Oh really? No. Oh,
because I've been hearing this shit.
If I just thought everybody how their
parents say crazy stuff like this. No,
really? No. Wow. Okay. I mean there's,
you know, there's different personalities.
Like I imagine, I don't
know, like my dad, you know,
he falls in line with a certain
personality type when it comes to that.
He doesn't say stuff like that. No, no.
Cause they, they're like, oh well can,
what are your, yeah, they're,
they're, they're kind of
like the overly devoted type.
Right. They go, there was nothing
better. I loved it so much. I mean,
you heard him on that phone call was,
I didn't mind change your diapers.
I love your shoes all over man and
care. He's that kind of love. Yeah.
Where it's like the over the, I mean, I
think there's, there's a middle ground,
but yeah. Your Dad, um, I mean,
I don't know if the standard,
you're not supposed to
say that kind of stuff.
Do you like it suck to
having yeah, a sign. Well,
I mean maybe that's why I have
such high self esteem. Yeah,
it's probably why I'm sounding
Romanian and hilarious though. Yeah,
totally secure. Grew up. Shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up is amazing.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
But he would tell me all the time,
go play on the freeway.
When you say shut the fuck up.
No, no, no. There's a joke.
But he would tell me I get lost and go
play on the freeway. Like if cause he,
he sounds worse than it is,
but like she would be drinking his beers.
You know what I mean?
Like my dad or it's a lie.
I know.
How does an adult, it sounds
really bad. Yeah. Okay.
So you know my dad drink like
a 12 hour every night, right?
That's normal. No, wait a minute.
Are you serious right now? Yeah.
You think that's normal? Well, it's,
I'm like light beer. It wasn't like,
it's not like always like Miller lite.
I want you to picture something real
quick. Just look at me. I can't,
none that I know this is wrong.
I can't, he wouldn't have a 12
right tomorrow.
Right. Okay. Well it
seemed normal at the time.
Well here's the light light beer,
Miller lite.
And the thing is I'm worried
about calories right now. No,
I think because he drank it was like,
I don't fucking know.
You know my dad was a blue collar guy.
I know he was a hard guy and he worked,
he worked on in the forklift business
for many years. He had his own business.
Really successful, you know, the
12 or a night is not injured.
Right.
But again,
I have to qualify it with like he
woke up for work at the crack of dawn,
this dude work hard fucking car and
was really successful. Functional,
totally high functioning something,
I don't know.
Right. So 12 or, and then like I'll be,
I'll be like eight or nine, I'd be like,
Hey dad, you want to play
golf? Play on the freeway.
And then finally I learned if I asked
him if I could have some of his beer,
like he put some in a cup for me
and then I, he put water in it.
Like I could sit next to him and
he was watching, he liked tennis,
so he'd be watching the tennis game with
a beer and if I drank some of it with
them, I could hang out with them. That was
a cool way to bond with your dad. Yeah,
it's weird, right? It's
that you understand what go
play on the freeway. Men,
I laugh. He would laugh and say it.
He'd go, go play on the freeway. C'Mon.
Gumline and it was a joke. It wasn't
like angry and I was kind of like,
okay, like I got the message to fuck
off so I would just go fuck off.
And that's the neat thing about being only
between like you're on your own years,
eight, nine and 10 somewhere
later in the beer game.
Yeah. But here's the thing. Well
my dad and his drinking though,
he never really changed.
It wasn't like he went from like,
well that's what happens.
One person tolerance when you
have 12 and nine what happens?
Right. But he never became angry or
shitty or solen like he was just,
he was himself. But with 12 years
it was kind of fucking weird.
And he's from the old country
too. You know, we have a
higher tolerance for, well,
my dad told me during communism, everybody
was drunk all day, like on their jobs,
cause there's no reason not to be sure.
The full,
what are you going to work hard for?
There was nothing to do.
We know about drink this bottle of vodka
and I'll see what I with a wrench. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Oh for sure. Old country.
Anyways. Okay, so go ahead, play it.
Play the audio. Who Care? My Dad
had to say about my childhood.
Tell me about when I was born. He said it
was the best three months of your life.
That was a worst three months of
my whole life. I never forget.
What was your favorite
part about a parent losing,
including escaping
communism, giving it an internment camp
in Italy. Correct. The refugee camp.
Refugee camp. Yeah. I know, but
this is worse. You been born,
this was worse than being a displaced
homeless immigrant who doesn't speak a
word of English at the age of 20?
Escaping from a horrible, yeah.
Did you drink beer when I was a newborn
because of, you know you can do it.
And that guy,
the go to the store to get the beer
because always have to take care of you.
What a what a miserable life with a good
thing that in Canada you could order a
beer to the house and they the beer
company, we're bringing it off.
No problem. And then so when dogs are
really losing their mind, the background?
Yes.
My cousin's shotty brought
over her two year old. Uh Huh.
And the dogs went bananas.
Just chase this kid and the dog Sefton
I'm the kid step in dog shit and
everything. It was really
fun. Really Fun. Okay. Yeah.
Drinking beer. How old was I when
you could hear about cleaning rods?
I'm so glad to hear that.
That was good.
Do you have any parenting
advice for me by a kid, Elise?
See I see at least a two.
Okay.
So that's my cousin shotty.
Who doesn't know what the fuck and be
conversations are and like she chimes in
all the time on everything.
Like I was on the phone with Ryan sickler
talking about like a sleep training,
right?
Because Ryan has a one year old Bella
and they sleep train her and I'm just
curious learning about it,
his method because it worked for them
and Mike fucking cousin is like listening
to my conversation on speaker phone with
Ryan and she's like commenting like,
no, it doesn't work. No, you can't
do it until he's six months old.
Like just try me in.
I'm like, motherfucker,
lemongrass is not your conversation
cause she shiny. That's what she does.
She just butts in your shit. Like
she, the personalities, like she just,
she knows everything about everything
and you're like, Bro, it's not,
this is not for you.
Like could you not fucking talk.
So okay. But anyway, so that's shotty.
It's shiny. I love you shiny. I love you.
But you know,
stay in B
electrically. I like chick. Yeah,
it shocks the kid had,
it falls enough floor sleeves that 15
minutes that comes at the leash bolts.
Like, why now? Why this kid's on fire?
Or I put in the stroller because
otherwise these ESOP cause,
see I thought it was rude of me
to buy her alleys and the airport.
I was watching this young kids
that just started to walk.
Thanks. One second. One second.
Then that kid is 30 yards away.
Oh yeah. You gotta have a leader
sometimes a short the bottom line.
I want to keep my appendix.
Yeah, just keep talking. That's so crazy.
Yeah.
Do you ever have people in your life that
just the no one's answering and still,
yeah. The thing is, okay, so the leash,
they took me to Europe when I was like
two years old and they put me on a leash
like a harness.
It's like a leather harness and there's
pictures of me in a leather harness and
let you guys couldn't just hold
my hand or something. Yeah.
We'll put you the leash. I don't
want to lose you. Okay, thanks.
Wow. That's pretty
crazy. Savage. Yeah. Wow.
No,
please don't.
Please don't go.
No.
Is this my therapy after it? My Dad?
Yeah. I'm trying to get you into play.
Shrink tomorrow. Yeah. How do you
feel as primal? Screaming, oh,
is this real or is this
real? Yeah, for real.
It all started. This whole thing began
and the primal scream therapy group.
This is fair.
Some people,
no, it's done. Really? Yeah. It's
like Burke. That's what I said.
Yeah, like if he lost a thousand pounds
and we're sweatpants. Yeah. Yeah.
Well,
very good at this.
The old hands could let go and be
crying within minutes or even seconds.
Great racking sobs and he leaves and those
scary silent moments when their lungs
would seize up
before the next on slot.
Fuck you. This guy. That's
terrible as it. Cool ponytail.
I know I sang on his shoulder.
He's going to touch it like crazy
loud when he wants you to see it.
That's why that he people would, pony
tells you have to display it. The men,
a guy and during one of my shows
this weekend was like Tom, Tom, what?
And he goes, look at it. Let me wear a
ponytail. He showed me his money down.
You have to show you, you have to
showcase it. If you're going to be a dude,
look at his deck. You can see it. I just
sweat pants. Yeah, you guys have great.
Yeah.
Sweaters don't look good on me and asked.
One woman was stalking me and
screaming, I hate you. I hate men.
And it's also like a bad act in class.
Yeah, that's what I thought this is. Yeah.
See you daddy.
You bastard
and a man in the group would take
this and run with it, but I'm bad.
I'm a man.
My Penis.
Just so you can see his
dick. That's great. That was
terrible. I hate these people.
Yeah. Can I tell you something? My
Dad is, we need to buy this for sure.
We're going to, yeah, it, my
dad's behavior is nothing,
I think is my mom was such a cray cray.
Then my dad seems normal by comparison.
Yeah. I mean that's why I'm not doing
this kind of stuff and crying in the fetal
position. How are you not crazier than
Shit television set comp. I swear to God,
like watching American TV and be like,
oh,
did you think though like
families are like that or just on TV?
No,
I thought that everyone else's
family was like that except for mine.
And like one day I might meet
people like that are really, yeah.
What about when you would hang out
with friends or boyfriends houses?
Like were they more normal to you? Yeah,
and that's why I wasn't home alone.
I was always in my France on his house
and shot, it was, his house was heaven.
They had tuna casserole and their
fridge and I was like her much so sweet.
Castro,
this sweet lady and she'd made there's
cookies on the counter and you're like,
wait, what? You guys have cookies
casserole? What's that like?
And now what about when she would come
to your house? But she like, ah, yeah.
Really? Yeah. I don't think she
liked, we didn't hang out at my house.
I have much because she was
more like, hey art. Like Ah,
like maybe my dad took us to Hungary. No,
that's right. We were like 18, and uh,
she's used to him now, so yeah.
She's been with my family forever.
She just used to it. Yeah. I,
we should ask her actually.
I'm not sure. Yeah, yeah. Uh,
but
yeah, I dunno. Wait, so what did you
think of, of like sitcoms and stuff?
Um, yeah, I dunno. I mean, I kind
of thought of it as, you know,
I knew that I knew that my, you know,
you're so aware of your foreign,
you have to foreign parents.
Yeah. But I had one,
so the distinction is what
really stood out there.
Like my dad was a pretty much
your standard American White Guy,
right? He was just Apple Pie, you know?
And my mom was like this total
alien, you know? So you really, yeah.
So it wasn't a IC, you're saying?
Yeah. You had some comparison.
The comparison is what would
kind of bounce you go, okay,
this is the American way of doing things,
right.
It's like the Latin way of doing things
and that's what stands out, you know?
And he has like,
he has such the eye ideal American
upbringing that we really would got get
America normalcy to the fullest and then,
and then she would put a little spices
on it and she would fuck you all up with
her bullshit. She would
do, she was just, it was,
that's what stood out is like
that, you know? Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Cause I really do feel like a,
an alien because both my parents were so
hardcore live here and grow up with two
foreigners.
Yeah.
You only think you understand as normal
is when you're with other people. Yeah.
Watching TV,
you got what are,
then you go to these houses and you see
how they are. I just thought it would.
Yeah. That was just their world. Got
a lot of other houses suck though too,
you know? Really. Yeah. I like my house. I
mean, I remember I would go to my buddies,
Dan Dan's house in Minneapolis and one
thing that they always had that we never
had was a bunch of junk food. And
I was like, ah man. Just every,
they had a one fridge that was just sodas.
Ah, that's cool. You're 10 years old,
you go like,
we're going to do that and just soda.
Yeah. Okay. My Dad had a fridge in the
garage just per fresca. FRESCA and bear.
Yeah. You weren't just
a quiet yeah. Hell yeah.
Shit.
Great.
There's uh, yeah, of that stuff.
But he had all the sugary drinks,
which has a 10 year old is really,
you know,
and the daily,
they limited what you could eat, your
parents. We just never really had that.
I mean,
it would just wasn't on,
we never were like throwing
it on the grocery list.
I never remember making that request.
It was that thing where we had
soda when you know it was, I dunno,
maybe a weekend and you ordered a pizza
and that's when you would always get
like a two liter with a pizza, you
know, delivered. That was the soda.
We didn't have 20 cans of [inaudible] her.
Yeah.
My Dad, we always had it in
my dad's. So we started to,
I feel like as we got older, but you
know, they back then when you're a kid,
that's when diet coke became the craze.
So my parents had diet coke in the
house and when you're young you're like,
this is fucking disgusting.
Anything as a kid tastes like shit.
And then all of a sudden, I don't
know, you turn 18, you're like, no,
it's pretty good. It's better
for me. Yeah. Yeah. So wow.
We didn't have, I mean, so I
remember his house being go,
but then I remember just weird,
weird people's houses.
I remember that going to the,
Oh, I had a friend that I liked,
actually my mom's um,
you know,
eccentric or different, um, normalcy was,
was normal to me because that's
home. That's what you grab. What?
I had a friend who, they are two
American, there were like too quiet.
I remember like nobody says shit
to each other and they had a goal,
like a fish pond in their house and me.
I was like,
I'm going to touch all these fucking
fishes. And so I was such an asshole.
I would touch all, they're really
expensive. Quite. Yeah. Oh my God,
that's such a deck yet. But they are
super, super reserved and I'm like,
you guys are weird. I don't, I don't
like quiet houses. That's the thing.
You know how Charles thing is like you
have to react. Told me like you love it.
So when people were reserved,
I always thought it was weird.
I always took it as this
like duplicitousness like Ah,
these motherfuckers are shady.
Like if you're not screaming,
I mean something is wrong.
I remember going to my buddy IRA's
place when I was a kid. Yeah.
Okay. It was a little, ah, where
did you grow up? There's no,
this kid was it, this is in Milwaukee. And
when I would wake up and know feeling
like Friday night or Saturday night there
before they drove us home,
they would toast bagels and melt
cheese on them. And I was like,
this is probably the best thing I've
ever had in my entire life. Huh. I'd,
I'd never, never had a Bagel
because you guys are not, you know,
so no funny little hats in
our house, but they, um,
I really did think that was the, and
I thought that was like Rad. I go,
I cannot wait to go to his house
again because, you know, I would say,
why don't we have that at our house? And
then in my house they would go like, Huh,
that was too ethnic. It was just
on your is I think, I dunno.
It was just like out of
the realm of possibilities.
I remember I begged my mom to, uh, to
bake something for me. I'd be like, mom,
like all the other moms,
they bake stuff for their kids.
Well fuck these are that a mom.
They don't
have to fucking work for a living. Like,
okay. I'm sorry. Good conversation.
It was fun. Yeah. You mean
a half hour your life. Okay.
Now I'm not talking like
make it from scratch.
Like just buy a fucking roll of
Pillsbury bitch. Yeah. Cut that shit up.
Put it in the oven. Oh, let me tell you
this before we get too far away from it.
Yeah. Um, so in, in we are
ordering this by the way.
Oh definitely. Yeah, we live and make a
note of that. Yeah, we've got to get that.
That's great.
I was in ball Sacramento this weekend.
And you okay there we get in,
we decided to go get some
pregame pretty showed meal.
We go to, uh, to get some smooshy. Mm.
So we go to this place,
it's really close to the
club and we order food.
It's media. It's just like, it's, it's
okay. As far as Sushi places, it's not a,
you know, it's not like, Oh wow, the
Sushi here is amazing, but it's like,
it does the job. You Go, it's not
bad. It's not great. It's fine.
It's not a succulent. Chinese
guests, not secular, but it's fine.
I order, we're done ordering. I'm
there. I'm up there with blue band. Um,
the bill comes, she drops off the bill.
Now I'm on a business trip and you know,
this is not unusual.
Most comedians or even people that just
travel for a living a lot to have their,
they're basically personal expense
card and your business expenses.
It helps you organize,
do your taxes and whatnot.
So I pull out my business card,
which happens to be American Express card.
I put it on there and I say, you
know, uh, ready to pay the bill.
So the server just kind
of very shortly rudely,
I, in my opinion,
responds visa, mastercard,
cash. No, she's a white lady
it sounds like. No, she,
she's a, she is a Hungarian
wizard. Just got a real treat.
Just that she is, yeah.
Do you want to just,
can we translate what you just said?
Old Pussy eyes. She's Asian. Yeah.
My Dad taught you that or your dad
did teach me. Okay, good. So wow.
She's a, yeah. Not from around these
parts and says visa, mastercard, cash.
And I go, she goes, which do
you have? Which is not, yeah,
it's not an appropriate answer.
It's,
yeah, you can, I think you can go, oh,
we don't take American Express. Right.
Not what he goes, what do you have? And
I go, this is what I have. She goes,
you don't have anything else.
And I at that moment I go,
it's kind of interesting that she
asks that because instead of saying,
instead of reiterating that they
don't take it right. She says,
you don't have anything else.
So I take my chances and say,
no, I don't have anything
else. In other words,
like how are we going to resolve
this? And she goes, okay.
And she takes the card and
she walks away and I go, oh,
I guess they do take it. You assume she's
going to use the card? Well, yeah. I mean,
she took it. She took it, she
leaves with it. She comes back,
know when she comes back,
she puts it down and she goes really
loudly so that the whole section of the
restaurant can hear. She goes,
your card declined. Oh yeah. Okay.
And at that point I'm bothered
for a number of reasons.
A, I know that she's lying. Yeah. Okay.
I'm 100% certain blackline and
I'm actually going, I'm, you know,
I'm about to investigate.
But the other thing,
the thing that really bothers me more
is that her tactic to get the form of
payment that she wants is that she's
trying to humiliate me. She's trying to,
she's banking on my announcement
that your payment has been declined,
is going to shame you into paying the
way I want you to pay instead of just
being straight forward. And from
the beginning, I'm sorry sir,
we don't take a minute to take it,
which you've heard probably many times
I've heard of before or deal with it
accordingly. But she left with the
car to run the card. Right. So she,
so when she said your car was a client,
I know for certain that she's lying
and just to vet, make sure I go,
okay, I flip the card over. I go, I'm
going to call the credit card. She walked,
she was like, kind of didn't anticipate
that that would be an option.
Walks away. Okay. Walk away.
I call the credit card company
American Express. Hey, what's up? Um,
I'm at a restaurant and they just
said that my card was declined.
Was it declined? No. And I said, well,
so what's happening? He goes, well,
there's no attempt made to
charge your card. I said, okay.
So now I'm pretty pissed about this, you
know, so she lied. She blatantly lied,
so then I go, Hey, I'm on the phone
with the credit card company. Yeah,
and the card wasn't declined
and she just goes to visa,
mastercard or cash and I go,
no, that's what she says.
Yeah, you, you call her out.
At this point I'm standing at the front
of the restaurant and it's getting,
you know, she's being loud. I'm being
loud. I said, visa master. She goes, visa,
mastercard or cash, and I go, no, this
is it. This is the only thing I have.
I didn't bring anything else. You're
going to have to run it. She goes,
your card declined. I go, no, it
wasn't. Then she takes the card again.
She swipes it,
she hits,
but she starts doing things like
hitting different buttons within.
After she swipes, see dark card,
declined card. So I was pointing to the,
to the monitor and I go, it looks
like he was saying, he goes,
your card hasn't been, there's no attempt
made to run your card for your card.
Hasn't been declined. And he goes,
your card was just used to rent a car,
which it was. It was just used in the
check into the hotel, which by the way,
they're so good about that. He goes, your
card, your card has not been declined.
I go, okay. So I said, you're going to
have to run the card or that's, you know,
it's going to be it. And
it starts to get, you know,
I could tell that she starts speaking
in her Pussy Samad language to somebody,
um, you know, starts talking some shit.
And I go, no, I'm not, I'm
not going anywhere. You're
going to have to run the card.
Yeah. You know, she,
she starts being more like verbal.
Like she goes,
no visa, mastercard. I go, all right,
I'm leaving. I go, I had a hat.
I lost that table. I go to grab it.
And she goes, Huh. And she runs,
she runs from the table back to the
front. He goes, I called police,
I called the police. This is for the
whole rest. The whole restaurant is seat.
You went back just for your hat. But I
also, I was implying that I was Bailey.
Oh. So like she got really scared.
And then as she, she's running,
she goes to pick up the phone and I go,
well pay the bill. And she goes, okay.
So I take the money, kind of, you
know, throw it on the counter.
And I said, as I left, I go,
I want you to know that you're a
liar and you're a bad person. Yeah.
Have someone translate that. And then
I walked out, wow, that's made up yet.
But I did say, you're a liar and
a bad person. Um, so anyways,
I was really fucking pissed about her.
And it wasn't about not
accepting American Express.
It was about the fact that I think, I
think she's a horrific human being. You,
she lied. It was like the whole room. It
was righteous. It was, yeah, it was a lie.
But it was, it was that the
attempt to publicly shame someone,
I think,
I don't think there's any end to how,
how much you should be shamed after that
for trying to get your way through that
method. I got back to the hotel, um,
I put an Instagram post
up later just saying,
this place is terrible.
Um,
I didn't even explain really why I
just said they were fucked up place
and then dude, it was
like, it was amazing. The,
uh,
the listeners of our show,
he didn't,
you unleashed mommy power around.
The problem is you gotta be careful when
you unleash mommy powers because they
are strong. They, it was
artwork. It is. This is, this is,
this is some of the modern art
masterpiece. What has happened?
I think this is like a happening. What
they used to call him the 60s. This is,
this is fucking art.
I have to commend,
I went so our listeners to know that
some of you are fucking legit comedy
writers. It was so
funny. I really don't. I,
I can tell you that if you had
people that listen to this show,
that we're professional comedy writers,
they were not,
they couldn't do it funnier than what,
you're funny.
These are pure fucking art dude.
Here are some of them. This is,
this is moments after it says,
warning,
this is not a poly by
friendly establishment.
My Mommy also developed an
Asian accent after we ate here.
She can't stop speaking in broken English.
Can someone explain
this? Ah, I'd rather move to the
Midwest. Ooh. Then eat here again.
Mommy told me not to go,
but my boy Tom and Mr. White folks was
in town saying some hoes and also making
Kim in airtight and Joe, right. My jeans
were a little high but not too tight.
I had a rectum role. And how do you say
an Asshole Ching Chong, Ching Chong.
Next thing I know Mike Tyson comes in
with Bruce Bruce and everyone said,
Hey Hitler, next time I will go somewhere
else. Most likely on the hundreds blog.
They don't even have any bikes and they
don't even know who big daddy Kane is.
I mean like they tied
in all the references.
The best part of this is that people who
don't know your mom's house are going
to read this. Like the average Yelper is
going to be like, what the fuck happened?
And this restaurant,
um,
read that one actually a pretty
good place. Definitely try the me.
So it's Hella Salty. The garden salad was
good, but the dressing was kind of wet.
So get that on the side. The staff
was nice. My server's name was DICO.
I thought that was inappropriate as I
was with a group of children overall.
These particular agents make a pretty good
Sushi. One Star, one star. I don't know.
I don't know if that was any to do
with our show. No, I think it was just,
I think someone's legit so made me
laugh. My server's name was Dick. Oh,
this is this one here. I read onstage
and it almost brought the house. Read it.
It said, this place really
makes my jeans low. End Loose.
I was treated like a calm
dog and called big words.
The food tastes like the devil's
driveway and made me brown a six.
You know what I'm saying?
For reals doe.
I almost threw so much Skype punches
like my boy crazy looks and shit.
In conclusion, this place seriously
needs to hide and tight in their jeans.
Before my mommy's and I ever consider
making their Sushi into brown ever again.
He asked if I had to choose between
eating here again and being retarded,
I would be retarded.
Good work babies,
baby. See that was from Norcross.
Georgia was really fun. I love,
I like the idea. He's like, I would
never make your food into Brownie yet.
That is actually what you do when
you go to a restaurant. You're like,
I choose your place to make my brown Brown
Brown. That's so interesting. I never,
that's so deep, bro. I never
thought of it that way.
Shout out to everyone out there and
doing their thing and stuff like that.
I came here to get my Sushi on. I was very
disappointed. I wore my cleanest done.
I'm gonna pull them up
over my retarded tests.
The customer service was the worst.
The fish smelled funny,
but the way she just said what?
It's only smells. It's okay.
It was very confusing because it clearly
was not only smells and was not okay,
and I made it to my squatty
potty. My, how you say rectum,
a straight seven.
I had to go shit to showers for reals.
Doe Next Stop Brown talk.
Know what I'm saying?
I would have to be a lot more
targeted than I already am.
So funny. That was like, how
many your mom's house references
can you squeeze in so good in 12 hours?
Yes.
Had like 81 one star
reviews fully written.
Hilarious. That was not even
meant. So look, I think they got,
they fully got what they deserved.
They've already managed to get a
bunch of the reviews removed. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Uh, you know,
I'm glad it caused them to think about
the way they treat their customers.
We don't have to, I'm not asking
you guys to bombard the more,
that's why I've attempted
to not mention them again,
but just know that, um, because people
were asking me like, well, what happened?
I told you what happened.
I felt extremely justified in
asking people to do that to them.
Um, and it's just, it's all in fun. I
mean, look, if they're being removed,
it's not going to harm
them. And as it's, you know,
it's a silly way of
getting back at a business.
That was shit that was shitty to me.
So, uh, but yeah, just the people go,
I wouldn't just do that. I
wouldn't for fun, say, Hey,
go fuck up these people's reviews just
for pure amusement or because like, oh,
I didn't think the Sushi was good,
but when I feel like, um, you know,
somebody mistreats me or miss [inaudible]
anyone then I don't think it's a,
it's really, you know, going
forward to ask for that. No,
but it's a funny way of getting back.
By the way, this Mug, do you remember,
I don't remember who gave
this to those crew. Yeah.
I don't know if he can see it
on the camera, but it's, it's,
it says empty jar guarantee
Australia and he made that. I know.
And then it says didn't,
doesn't smell done burn integrase
and it's got chuck Woolery.
We just emailed each other yesterday.
Yeah.
This is like my favorite cup and
the house. It's great. Yeah. Yeah.
They made a couple of those, a couple
of go's crew one those funny did. Uh,
Chris and Pete. Yeah. Shout
out to both of you guys
doing your thing and stuff like that. I
know. For real though, y'all are busy.
Yeah. So there's, um, this
I've been wanting to show you,
we have so much to share so much today.
I've collected materials you've
collected. Aw, he's back. So this,
we haven't played them in a
while. Um, but he's in the news.
Did you know he's in the news
now. I'll get to that. Just
to give you an idea. Yes.
This is Brian Silva,
um,
otherwise known as a vine star
who rolls in swag and he makes,
he made a lot of videos talking
about how dope he is and you know,
it'll take your girl and yeah.
Doing this thing, stuff like that.
He was doing his thing. He's really
into his body and his physique and is,
it looks great. It's always like,
by the way, you know, as a fat guy,
nothing irritates me more
than somebody who's super,
super thin and it goes like, I'm
super muscular. No, you're not.
You're just really skinny. I like his
body. You do. I, I'd like to have it. Oh,
he's got like a lady's body.
It's a nice figure. Yeah. Yeah.
It's not even a regular body.
It's like a 60 [inaudible] guy who I look
at it and I think what a nice figure.
That's, yeah, like a lady.
That's what I'm saying.
I wouldn't mind having a teenage boys
physique. That's nice for a lady.
Here's what,
um,
here's to give you it to familiarize
you with his brand work. Uh,
here's a little backstory on it. It was
a little bit of what he used to put up.
Okay.
Yeah. Seems hollow tips will
be on your dinner plate.
I keep a full clip on my hip.
That will knock you off. The map
on the SAB is Nigga,
I'll leave your head old
was good bitch sweat. It was mad. Yeah.
You Mad.
Cause I'm a god Nigga.
You know, he drops big words
and does, sure it does. That's
a way with it. Well, uh,
he might, that might change
pretty soon. Ah, okay.
There's a little bit of of,
um,
news like as I was mentioning that
will make you reconsider your language.
Here is, uh, some news
that aired about Mr. Silva
over the weekend.
Silva is the man who
surrender to Charlottesville
police following a multiple
hour standoff on Sunday.
The 25 year old would not talk about
what led up to the dispute norm.
Why he barricaded himself in the house.
Brian Silva except excepted Nbcu 29 for
request for an interview at the jail.
We should,
so he's being,
they shouldn't clip of him being so I
guess he held somebody in the home at
gunpoint and here he's being as chord
with his pants around his knees.
I'm surprised he's 25 more than anything.
I thought this kid was like 17. Wow.
Yeah.
For not knowing what to expect.
And all silver would say is free
me over and over again today.
Silver stuck to a single message. How
do you think you should be free? Okay.
I told him a big mix up
and they confusion. Truman,
that's all I have to say. Thank you. No,
it would not address why he took the
social media and posted videos while
barricaded inside that house.
Hmm. So, um, yeah,
as he was held up in this house,
he posted multiple videos. Um, you know,
like things that he's famous for.
Um, no I see there's the cops, um,
outside of the house. Um, stuff like
this, check it out, stuff like that,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You know,
did as 12 hate no Nigga
to are there for bill.
My big head,
big Zack Nigga fucking rocking.
She clocked up my fucking pocket.
Fuck them Niggas Nigga.
Yeah,
you've seen juts out and say bid
right there. And I knew right there.
Pretty good
shout though. I'll give him that black
voices on fleek. It's pretty good.
I mean it could,
maybe we could use some of it for Tom
or black Tom or black or Brian silver.
Why Mr. White Folk of white folks?
I'm to motherfucking combos.
Yeah. He's so dumb. This
kid the dumbest. Yeah,
he's pretty bad.
Big fucking dude.
Shit.
They got totally
suck my Dick Nigga.
What up? What up Nigga?
You ain't got at least
and that's funny. He went
from that to free me. Free me.
Why should it be? It's just a
big mix up. Mm hmm. I love the,
I love a guy who was talking the most
shit to himself. He's out of his mind.
Do you think he's on math?
Some sandals wrong?
I don't know.
I think you know math makes
you real paranoid and like,
remember the Henry or old driver is like
how to do math and just look through
the peephole. Here's a lot of
crack. Oh, that was cracked.
I goes, my theory, I
don't know. I think he's,
he's a little jacked up on something.
Yeah,
Dude.
Bitch ass little niggas.
They hate him. I hate my
shit right there. I see you
like, I ain't got shit. Fuck Nigga.
I swear to God.
I swear to God
I gotta follow this guy and find these
are great. You don't have to, hey,
this is down to 7% that is,
it looks like this over here.
No, that's not the monitor. It's
get her. Okay, good looking good.
Looking at look good.
Look.
He just freely uses the n bomb like that.
He thinks he's black.
That's the craziest part. He's 25 years
old and he calls himself the n word.
He gave himself permission.
That's for sure. Did he calls
White People Caucasians?
Fraud. You wouldn't know about
that cause you Caucasian.
He's like he's under,
he's underprivileged.
You know he's a victim that you're
probably right that he probably goes,
all these Caucasian mother
fuckers came through.
He identifies as being
discriminated against.
I don't know how but wow.
It's certainly something Brian,
myself kind of makes you go the km
one. I like that a lot.
She's so inquisitive.
What I want to know is,
what I want to do is where's,
where's the come Tom and I'll tell you
just to make sure I watched that video
just to vet it.
Probably.
Did she find it? A bunch of it?
Yeah. A lot of it was hiding.
He was hiding in these guys balls
in bags and then she finds it.
I even had, I made sure I'm blue man. You
checked it out. What did you say? Yeah,
she found it. She found the account. Yeah.
It wasn't mean balls.
Old Texts and I love sudden,
and what I want to know
is where is to come.
That's the long version. Oh, I, cause
I was confused. Yeah. I'm glad it is.
Contextualized.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, and well, I'm just happy
that she found it. It was like a nine.
I need to know anything.
Hey, when young girls are lost
like that. Yeah. Um, where's that?
What's that clip where the guy's like,
oh, those balls full accom Cominos bulls.
Oh,
who's that?
That's a guy that picked up a good cameos.
Borrowing addicted, prostitute,
male prostitutes. Right.
It's a question if there's kind of in
the moment and he's like, are there any,
he goes, you got a beautiful,
is there any common those balls?
Is that that New York a? Yeah. You
got a need coming. Those balls.
Yeah. You like uncircumcised guys
as as I recall, right? Yeah. Yeah.
All right, cool. Yeah,
I like radio ads and blonde.
Pretty close as close to him blind and
that's my clothes at all. It's not close.
That's why we hang out a little bit.
Which one do you want?
How much can you give me?
2030 okay.
Come on.
I wouldn't even talk to that guy
for $30 let alone stuck his day.
How about how much can you give me? 20.
I'd be like, all right man, I gotta go.
Yeah.
What's Tom's Tom Segura blowdry worth?
You know,
think he's good? He's letting
his dick get sucked. Okay.
Oh
right. Well I have, I dudes want
that for free. That's not like, yeah,
yeah, but this guy wants
to suck them. Right.
See a lot of checks or like
a lot of girls come up to me
after shows and they're like, how
much does suck that Dick? Sure.
Busy right now I'm busy. Yeah.
How much you got in there?
Like 20. I'm like, shh. And then
you're like, where's the com
back to his place. You have to call before
you come over. I ain't never come. Uh,
come uninvited and don't worry about that.
Sure.
Tastes good.
So you got any common those bulls reminds
me for some reason I think of like a
deli. Like that's the guy that
works behind the deli. Pastrami.
You got any coming those balls you want
to Cherry Cola and come and your balls.
It's like it that, that accent
is not sexy. No. For that
kind of context. It's not,
you know,
it's not good.
He Ganny come and your balls got
any those balls like it's not right.
We've got a Chucky I'm
right. Yeah, exactly.
Looking for a guy would come and he's
bald, right? Yeah. How about southern?
Hey y'all, you got nick and your
balls. Like that's kind of nicer,
different role. Tad that um, this guy,
he just sounds grimy. Yeah, it's
a rough, it's a rough, yeah,
it's a harsher accent for sure.
Cominos Bulls.
That's like your uncle Ira.
Yeah. What? He's heard you
off on the Ferris wheel, Babe.
So I got this song that you
sent me. Did I? Um, yeah,
he did.
Oh, we're going to do that now. I
think so. My God, I'm so excited.
I've been holding off watching it
because I wanted to watch it with you the
first time, so I haven't
actually watched a lot of these.
Okay. What was, I want it
to be a surprise. This is,
I'm so excited. Our man, we've,
we've played them on the
show before. Um, his name is,
Ooh. Does he have come in
his balls? He's got coming.
Is Bulls them?
Is Nick Hoc if you don't know.
He's so amazing.
He's one of the main hose on the show.
Gigolos on showtime.
God. And it's so much, nick is,
he's, you know, he's obviously,
he's the hardest worker in the room.
I'm more compassion, the most competitive.
It's very competitive in the gym.
Seven days a week we're going to go sweat
takes care of himself physically. Um,
really goes after it as a hoe.
But um,
on top of that he's also a rapper over
working on my raps and as a rapper.
Um, even on the show he got called out
by one of the other hose. Yes. Hey,
hold on. Just, you know he's
from Juggalos. Did we say
that? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's super airbrushed here by the
way. Yeah. I mean that's really,
but no, I'm sorry. Those tattoos are
this shitty in real life too. Yeah,
but they've also airbrushed or whatever.
Wait in real life. How do you know?
Cause he had come in his balls and I found
it. No you don't. I've seen a TV show.
They can't do it for TV every week
and look at it. Look at this mess.
What the fuck? It was way crazier.
Now what is that? It's way crazier.
Is that a cover up like he had some
swastika isn't, no, it's like, um,
I don't know. Drinking too
much coffee. What? Like,
like a cover up those swots because
if you're going to be a hoe here,
I'm going to ask my cousin Julie. Julie
listens to the show. Julie. What the fuck?
Like why,
why this mass?
It doesn't look good. It can't
be, can't be the primary tattoo.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
It looks fucking tissue. Your
watch it my favorite. No,
she loves, it's our show though.
Okay. So maybe she'll ay Yay. Yay.
It's great. It's so,
it's so much a nick man.
Nick Cock. Let's see. Can I tell
you, I'm like, I'm not, I just,
I hate on his level of, uh, he just
front so hard right now. It's, um,
I know you can't really Yai.
Yeah. And he's got his little nip nip
pierced and oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's, it's a lot men, the guys a
lot. I think when men are this fit,
personally for me, it's very feminine.
It's very vain and a feminist.
What I'm talking about.
No,
I'm Sarah and I'm not just saying that
because you're not to be a people pleaser
here, but I'm serious. Not attractive to
me. Well, it's not just being in shape.
It's the way that you present how you were
in shape. It's vain. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's wanting to be fit.
But like this, this
is ridiculous. You're ridiculous
man. Oh my life. Yeah. Oh my,
he's added a lot. Yeah. That
earlier shots. Sure. Um, anyways,
this is not what we're, we're
not focusing just on nick. Yeah.
I mean like tattoos in and
of themselves are not lame.
This Guy Kinda want to talk
about his new song. My fuck. Um,
this actually came out fucking last week.
Oh,
so we, yeah, we've played, yeah, I know.
We've played breaking this guy. Dammit.
We're breaking, breaking a sweat.
The name of this song,
if you listen a few episodes back,
I don't remember the episode
number. We could look it up. We, uh,
we talk about his rap battle with then
we played on the show that they were on
was Gigolos. So anyways, this came in,
it's a song that he's put out. It's
called breaking a sweat. I, I'm sweating.
I will do, I'm so embarrassed for
him already. Well you shouldn't be.
I think we should have legitimately give
him a shot and let the listeners decide
whether or not this is a good song.
And I was like, radio stations do that.
They're like, is it hot or not? Like call
us, let us know. You can't really call us,
but you can certainly let us know.
Oh,
you can certainly comment on
youtube on the video itself and let,
let a brother know if he's on the right.
All right, so here it is.
It's court. Okay. Ah, Shit.
Breaking a sweat. Hold on, hold on. I got
to get ready. Are you ready? Here we go.
Okay.
That's correct.
Cold bed.
The Ketchup.
My take off like a jet is a
sense that you watch too much TV.
You don't know who get met.
I'll never forget,
I said it doesn't make sense.
Milk
your boy
so far. It's really good. Holy Shit.
[inaudible] I can't be bro.
Daddy sweating those balls. Oh Man. Well,
we're all wondering is where's the comm?
So wait,
where's the video?
I thought we were going to
see some visuals and I'm
upset that I hope he makes a
video for breaking a sweat, but it does
look like he has a bunch of other songs.
Cool. I'm ready. I'm ready.
Are you, are you going to,
do you want to get into all
of them? All right. This song,
what's the verdict on breaking a
sweat? It's terrible. It's really bad.
It's terrible. You're really, this
is, this isn't your best work.
This is a really bad song. But in
mixed defense, you buy an album.
A lot of times you go, sure you know it's
an accomplished musician and you say,
sure, yeah, this isn't their best song.
Maybe this not, maybe not this number.
Maybe another number. What about born
to be bad? Sure. It's got eight views.
It's breaking a sweat is 20
and this is pretty bad, Huh?
It's like kind of an original premise.
Let's see if one to be bad is um,
his good.
Okay. I'm so embarrassed
already. What part?
Okay.
10 seconds in. It's better than breaking
a sweat. I'll tell you that. Yeah.
This is better than breaking a sweat.
I like the artwork. Yes. It's um,
it's 15 different loads from him.
Yeah. Yes, man. He's very emo.
Must be restored. Shit. My mind, why
are you can't blame me for reading.
Blocking my fire. I paid a lot
more. I walked a tight. Wow.
Wow.
I keep hearing these voices scream in
Poland and I listened. Dangerous Wall.
They had four paces, blah, blah,
blah, blah. And I'm sick of waiting.
All right. Yeah. Is it me or is,
is it off the timing? Like he,
he raps not in time where there's
a lot that's off. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Is there a, is there
an actual video or no,
these are all just the songs.
A gigolo four views.
Four months ago I was put on group.
He pitches step up.
What do you want to hear? I'm
out of this world. We fight. Um,
it's up to you. Oh look, leave. Leave
with me. No. Tipping in and has 103 views.
It might be the song of the album.
Is that the breakout hit?
It could be if it's got 103 views
and this is the last one. Okay.
It hurts my soul. I think we should. Yeah,
we should give it a break after this.
So this is our last shot.
We're going to go with the
highest viewed song on the album,
a tipping in sip and let's
see what happens. Here we go.
[inaudible]
anything
past the past I didn't give
some tracks.
It's not good.
It's better than the other two songs.
Then for those 26 seconds it was, you
know, it's really hard to do. What's that?
To have a video up performance on
youtube and only have two views.
That's actually really hard.
Does not have a lot of videos that have
such a low view count and they're able
to have two views
and it's been up for four months.
Even someone stumbled on it
accidentally and I was like,
it looks like it's his page
here.
He doesn't have,
he doesn't have a good cadence.
It doesn't have to be a voice for rapping.
He isn't good at actually writing lyrics
and this is a bad path for him to take
that good. Yeah. Can I talk like man,
I'm going to throw it out here. Yeah,
he's failing is you see how there's like
12 personalities of nick hoc and that?
Yes. That's the problem. The guy doesn't
know who he is and what he stands for us.
If you watch the show too, he'll show up
at the bar. Like this guy in the middle.
You don't know who this guy is the next
day he feels like this. Yeah, I know he's,
he doesn't know who he is.
Confused. It's all right.
He needs to pick an identity people
awhile sometimes. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
the thing is
[inaudible]
who do you think you are? I am
something to think about, right?
Yeah. Something to think
about, to think about.
So I have this to show you.
The life is pretty cool,
confused young man, man. That's,
it's all about something's wrong.
Everything here, it's all bad. Ain't
start taking that off. I feel better now.
It makes me feel weird.
I feel uncomfortable.
I feel his pain or something.
I don't know. Yeah. I feel
like something's wrong. So,
um, oh, okay. Old School. This
little episode you were on. Yes.
I was on this episode of [inaudible] two
wraps, man. Miss you. I'm to be wrapped.
I really loved that show.
That show, man. It was,
it was seriously what I look
forward to so much during the week.
What's the,
what day was this on?
This was on, what is it?
Original air dates? It was,
was it a weekend show? Friday.
Saturday? I can't remember now. I used
and I used to never miss it. That's funny.
I used to watch 120 minutes every
Sunday night on MTV at midnight. Yeah.
It was a good one to stay up for.
And they play all the alternative
videos with the third no videos anymore.
And MTV, right? It's gone. Oh
yeah, it's done. It's a shit show.
Shows 88 to 95. Damn. I feel like it
was on longer than that. It's fun. Yeah.
Yo,
MTV remedy raps.
Um, it used to add lover was
on there, right? Oh yeah.
I remember seeing flavor flavor on this
show for the first time and being like,
what the fuck Dr Dre and Ed Lover. But
it was a different doctor dre. Right.
The big guy right there. You see, right.
Right to dry and there's Dj dad mouth.
Yeah. Um, and the J Paulie bye.
Yeah. I mean, I remember
watching, I remember watching a,
like certain episodes stand out to me.
I remember when Wu Tang was on
yo MTV raps and they did the,
the mystery of chess boxing.
Um, it's like the, one of the,
it looks like the enter the 36
chambers cover like those masks on.
And I was hearing that sound, it was
a sound I'd never heard before. Like,
what the fuck is this?
That was like the introduction to Wu Tang
was from Yo MTV raps. Oh, okay. To me,
you know, and probably to most people
why kids are watching 120 minutes. Yeah,
I know. I know. It was
pretty awesome though.
I remember it was seeing Redman
and are a lot of you anyways.
Here's Eric B and rock him.
Eric B and Rakim. I like these
two. No, Rakim, Rakim, Rakim,
raw McKean. Let's see, Eric Bay
rack card. I love, I've got to would be
a rock of the video. One of my favorites.
I like,
I like that dude.
I listen to my lyrics. You know what
I'm saying? To keep me on my thing.
You know what I'm saying?
That of that nature.
I'll listen to like a Bob James Best
part of this interview.
So it's Eric B and Rakim probably the
first time they're on yo MTV raps and
they're asking him like, so what do
you, what do you like to listen to?
And his first,
I think it's his first answer
is I listened to my shit. Yeah.
So what's your inspiration?
Me? Yeah, he's smart guys.
I'll let you know my lyrics.
I listened to her like that. Good. I'd
take her best days when the light bulb.
Tom, what's your favorite comedy? Me.
I listen to my own shit, my jokes.
So I remind myself of what I'm all about.
That's what you just said.
What was that guy in the back?
What's that motherfucker doing?
It's like just chilling man.
That is just chilling. He lied.
He was supposed to be there.
Dave Brown still my
main thing still it had,
I lived in a little bit of
everything north name because
the type of music I relate
to them on the plane.
Wow.
You know what I'm saying?
That was the filming I'm talking
about and just to be sure,
just to make sure we know we have a dozen.
This, this reminds me, this
makes me, um, I don't know.
This seems so authentic.
It is.
This is a time where like MTV actually
broke music and musicians where music
should, like these guys were
really fucking musicians. Yeah.
Not this horse shit of today.
These guys are real fast trying to make
it as music. Yeah. Like this was genuine.
I mean these are low shit.
Nick Hawks a yesteryear, right?
This is before the time of the Internet
and in competition shows where people
thought they could just make a, hey, I,
I'm a musician. Look at me on youtube.
Like these motherfuckers really
did it fucking chain on Eric beat.
It's awesome that you guys got them
with the Mercedes. Yeah, of course.
That was so cool.
But back then that was like,
what do you think has chain
ways on Eric is so heavy. Yeah.
That's like a 25 pounds away.
His neck down. Yeah, for sure.
I want to get one of those. Yeah.
And you should spend a lot on it. No,
I'll I get a fake one. It's just
all about the look, you know. Okay.
I'll you started going to meetings that
I want you to spend money rope chain 25
grand or something.
Yeah.
But really personalize it so
that the resale value is low.
Alright,
here we go.
Don't say anything.
What I'm saying,
here's why that's good. Short
interview. Lots of trail. Yeah,
the ratio is good on there. Yeah.
Nah mean no to hell. We don't,
you ain't see anything yet.
And it's a mainstream show,
which is even better. Yeah.
Yeah. You know what I'm saying? No,
to give him a run for his money cause
we were like, that's pretty cool.
You got the God Mc right there.
That's, you know, rock him. Um,
is there anything we
can put them up against?
And then we have this from del,
the Funky homosapien.
Oh, I'm, I know that you
gentlemen as well. Yeah.
So let's see how he
does on this right here.
Everybody, a rash should be unified. We
all wrapping. You know what I'm saying?
So what I'm saying is why don't
we just build a bad ass man?
Like we ain't got to be told me there.
You might not like somebody,
you know what I'm saying?
But that don't mean you say,
hey know or nothing like that.
You know what I'm saying?
That's not what I'm talking about.
To pop as one,
you know what I'm saying? She
be unified. So check this out.
It's a wrap.
Since we married about six
years old,
he's a kid
but not living, you know,
you know what I'm saying?
This, I think even if Nick Hawk, we're
just start doing interviews this way,
he'd be a better rapper then.
He knows that too.
Yeah. But do you see how back then it was
like you fucking started a craft. Yeah.
Uh, being a musician at the age
of like 14, and not only that,
people actually talk like people,
it wasn't all about like,
I got this motherfucking homes, I've
got money bitches. Yeah. I'm so fucking,
I'm awesome. I'm awesome. I'm awesome.
Like this guy is actually saying
Ramazan is one of the best things.
It's one of the foundations of being
a great MC, right. Is I'm awesome.
And there's actually a lack of,
I'm awesome now because what you would
say you're awesome about it. Yes.
You need to say you're awesome about
your skillset right now. It's like,
I'm awesome. I own shit. Or like
material in it, you know? Yeah.
I have a lot of jewelry,
but back then it was like, you don't
want to fuck with my style. Right.
And how my flow is just, you
know. Right. It's unmatchable, um,
the nic hoc of, of you
know, of the rap world.
And so that's what you would say, you
can't fuck with me on. And it was awesome.
Not My stuff. Look at all the shit that
I have. Yeah. Now it's like, exactly.
He's like, I got six houses, 20 cars.
That shit's boring. Yeah, I agree on that.
But you definitely want to say that.
You cannot fuck with me on a mic.
That's what it's all
about. Right? Right. Yeah.
This guy is actually talking
about other stuff. Yeah.
It's just refreshing to see a rapper or
talk about stuff other than bitches and
money and all we had to do was go back
to 25 years to get somebody to say some
people were people on television to even
watching those guys on new MTV raps.
Ed Lover. Yeah. He just acted like a
person, dude. Yeah. It wasn't like,
hey,
like totally fucking phony Malone.
Yeah. They used to have
the, the real kind of a,
it's a wacky now it's like a wacky
persona. Like they have to act.
They can't be like, Hey, what's up?
Welcome back. Right. He was like,
he really was himself there
and it's so much more relaxing
and engaging to watch. Yeah.
Like I actually wanted to see what
they're, what they're talking about.
Cause they were normal.
Yeah.
Maybe that's why people like podcasts
now cause we're not fucking being phony
retards. Yeah, yeah. Cheeses. I know.
That's why I saw lobular how la La la,
he really killed it on that.
You know what I'm saying?
It's a much longer interview. So
again, you gotta go, you know where,
where do you stand on that?
You know, where are you?
You know what I'm saying? The old
man, you know what I'm saying?
I'm saying, you know what I'm
saying? You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying? You know what
I'm saying? You know what I'm saying?
I'm saying? You know what I'm saying,
by the way. Well, you know what I'm
saying? You know what I'm saying?
By the way, big props to, uh,
the guy that did the interview
in a loud environment.
So you hear just boom and music playing
in the background the whole time.
Now is this guy from ban the Pharcyde
del, the Funky homosapien. What is he in?
He's in, um, phone it Funky Homosapien Oh,
I thought it was a band I ever glyphic.
Ah,
I don't know who are this
is really that. Yeah. Um,
I like how it cuts to like his different
poses. What do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah. It's even a year. Yeah. Yeah. That's
great. That's great. He's a great, yeah,
you can't, you can't talk.
You know what I'm saying?
Now this one I'm going to like simply
oh, okay. It's a sounds, sound word.
Um, I like this one because of the
change. You know what I'm saying?
And posing and over the span of a,
a longer interview.
Now I know in your world he had a couple
of didn't count there cause he said yes.
And then those don't count.
Now I heard to you knows too.
I might be wrong, but I would say overall
is, you know what I'm saying? Peace.
This is a very strong submission.
Okay, very good. This might,
this might be top 20, top
20, 20. I would say it's,
it's higher up than that. Really?
Yeah. Real. Yeah, man, that was,
that was unbelievable. That was
really good. What do you think?
Um, I don't know. Tom. You
don't know. All right. Well, um,
we should, uh, we should get moving
here. We've been, we've been at, oh no,
Auntie Fifi. You want to
hear that? I'd love die.
We have to choose two were
tweeting to each other. Uh, she,
she retweeted something and I, you know,
we got into it on Twitter a little bit.
I said, we miss you. Where is your music
onto? Fifi where's your music? Okay.
And she made something just for us to
play. So I wanted to give it to where,
you know, okay. Okay. Well we
don't remember Auntie Fifi,
uh, she's been on the show.
She's a nice lady from Texas and she
makes all these really uplifting songs,
um, out of like nothing. She'll be sitting
in our living room and she'll be like,
Jack and Jill went up the
hill to fetch a pail of water.
You got to stay positive
and drink your water.
Like it just blows
places that nobody knows,
which is so special.
And she's such a trade.
I really wanted to give her as a treat for
the, for the kids. Yeah. No, I love her.
I love on GP. Felicia. Sweetest
lady. This is a, this is is
old version of her Facebook.
Hello Facebook.
Good afternoon.
I was sitting here thinking about this
New Year and how is the new year all over
the land.
As I was sitting here pondering that,
I picked up a pen and a
piece of paper and these
are the words that came
to me at that time. Okay.
You wrote a song and original time maybe
I shared them with you. Facebook. Yes.
Thank you.
Social media.
There's a landing
pad and paper
from cow.
Yeah,
from the red
to the Gulf stream.
This man made for you and
God, we thank you. Buy The land. We
take it by the Land Hall in new. Yeah.
And because we have the land,
we thank you for the farms and the song
says old Macdonald had a farm Molyneux
yeah.
And on his farm he had some bigs
all care everywhere.
Oh,
Mcdonald had a farm.
E
and Gabi because do we have pigs?
There's shillings a day and when I tables,
God,
you're so mindful of your people
and we have children's today.
God,
Hallelujah.
You're a mindful guide.
You're a mindful God.
She's full of the spirit guide. You
hit her up. I do love Ozzy for you.
Hit her up and I said, where
have you been? Yeah, I go
onto fee fee. Where are you?
How are you? She goes, how
are you? I go, good. We miss
our auntie. Where's the music?
We miss our songs and then she sent me
one. Bam. Straight away or she goes, okay,
here's Auntie fee fee
singing just for Christina
just to be,
not to be confused with Auntie fee.
That's a different auntie and auntie
feet cooks sweet treats for the kids,
but this is different bounty fee
fee. This is two feet gts. Trademark.
Wow.
Why main name man?
Whoa. Watch me. We
Eh
and watch me nae man.
You better work.
She's a sweetheart. She's sweet lady.
Voice on her though. She can sing.
She can sing.
Fifi now that you heard her song and you
love her at Auntie underscore, right?
Fee Fee,
fee,
fee fee with a y underscore
fee to two e's and
another flat or no, your mom's house
lumps her. She's the best dude.
Oh,
okay.
Chitlins God,
you're a mindful guy.
We have to pick a song to
go out on a filler up. Oh,
there's a filler up contest.
We have submissions. Oh, okay.
Cuba as for more submission.
Okay. More submissions.
We need more fill her up submissions
and we'll play them next time.
Um,
so please send them in to your mom's
podcast@gmail.com there's no house.
Your mom's podcasts taken guys?
Yeah,
your mom's podcasts@gmail.com you
can send a bunch of, you know,
any email you want it there,
but the specialty please in the subject
line put fill her up if you're sending a
fill her up submission.
Let's see. Somebody sent a
crazy look song. Is it good?
Really?
It's in the fan song thing.
Oh yeah. Okay. Here we go.
This is our interpretation
of a collaboration between
crazy loaves and pillow
pants. Okay. High and tight. Okay. Okay.
All right. All right. Well, we're
going out on this. Let's, uh,
we'll see what happens. All
right. Bye guys. Thanks for
listening. Thank you mommy.
Damn. For Real. Crazy.
Yeah.
A film,
the film.
Mm hmm.
Yes.
Yeah.
Mm hmm.
Yes,
yes.
We'll make it
blah,
blah.
Dog Stuff.
Yeah.